FEMALE SPEAKER: The following
content is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so my name is Ben
Olken and we're going to
be talking about how to think
about sample size for
randomized evaluations.
And more generally that the
point of this lecture is not
just about sample size but we've
spent a lot of time,
like in last lecture, for
example, thinking about the
data we're going to collect.
Then the question is, well,
what are we going to
do with that data?
And so it's about sample size
but also more generally, we're
going to talk about how do we
analyze data in the context of
an experiment.
OK.
So as I said, where we're going
to end up at the end of
this lecture is, how big
a sample do we need?
But in order to think about how
big a sample we need, we
need to understand a little more
about how do we actually
analyze this data.
When we say, how large does a
sample need to be to credibly
detect a given treatment effect,
we're going to need to
be a little more precise about
what we mean by credibly and
particularly think a little bit
about the statistics that
are involved in thinking
through--
evaluate--
understanding these
experiments.
And particularly, when we say
something that's credibly
different, what we mean is
that we can be reasonably
sure, and I'll be a little bit
more precise about what we
mean by that, that the
difference between the two
different groups-- the treatment
and control group--
didn't just occur by random
chance, right?
That there's really something
that we'll call statistically
significantly different between
these two groups, OK?
And when we think about
randomizing, right?
So we've talked about which
groups get the treatment and
which get the control, that's
going to mean that we expect
the two groups to be similar
if there was no treatment
effect because the only
difference between them is
that they were randomized.
But there's going to be some
variation in the outcomes
between the two different
groups, OK?
And so randomization is going
to remove the bias.
It's going to mean that the
groups-- we expect the two
different groups to be
the same, but there
still could be noise.
So in some sense, another way of
thinking about this lecture
is that this lecture is
all about the noise.
And how big a sample do we
need for the noise to be
sufficiently small for us to
actually credibly detect the
differences between the two
different groups, OK?
So that's what we're going to
talk about is basically, how
large is large so we can
get rid of the noise?
And let me say, by the way, that
we've got an hour and a
half, but you should feel free
to interrupt with questions or
whatever if I say something
that's not clear because
there's a lot of material that
we're going to be going
through pretty quickly.
OK.
So when we think about how big
our sample means to be--
remember, the whole point is how
big does our sample have
to be remove the noise that's
going to be in our data?
And when we think about that, we
think essentially about how
noisy our data is, right?
So how big a sample we need is
going to be determined by how
noisy is the data and also how
big an effect we're looking
for, right?
So if the data is really noisy
but the effect is enormous,
then we don't need as
big of a sample.
But if the effect we're looking
for is really small
relative to the noise in the
data, we're going to need a
bigger sample.
So actually, sometimes it's
the comparison between the
effect size and how
noisy the data is.
It's the ratio between
these things
that's really important.
Other factors that we're going
to talk about are, did we do a
baseline survey before
we started?
Because a baseline can
essentially help us reduce the
noise in some sense.
We're going to talk about
whether individual responses
are correlated with
each other.
So for example, if we were to
randomize a whole group of
people into a given treatment,
that group might be similar in
lots of other respects.
So you can't really count that
whole group as if they were
all independent observations
because they might be
correlated.
For example, you all just
took my lecture.
So if you all were put in the
same treatment group, you all
were exposed to the treatment
but you also all were exposed
to my lecture and so you're not
necessarily independent events.
And there are some other issues
in terms of the design
of the experiment that we'll
talk about that can help
affect samples as well, like
stratification, control
variables, baseline data, et
cetera, which we're going to
talk about, OK?
So the way we're going to go in
this lecture is, I'm going
to start off with some basics
about, what does it mean to
test a hypothesis
statistically?
And then when we get into
hypothesis testing, there are
two different types of
errors that we're
going to talk about.
They're helpfully named type
I and type II errors.
And you have to be careful not
to make a type III error,
which is to confuse a type
I and a type II error.
So we'll talk about
what those are.
Then we'll talk about standard
errors and significance, which
is, how do we think about more
formally what these different
types of errors are?
We'll talk about power.
We'll talk about the
effect size.
And then, finally, the factors
that influence power, OK?
So this is all the stuff
we're going to go
through, all right?
So in order to understand
the basic concepts of--
when we're talking about
hypothesis testing, we need to
think a little about
probabilities, OK?
Because all this comes down,
essentially, to some basic
analysis about probability.
So for example, suppose you had
a professional-- and the
intuition here is that the more
observations we get, the
more we can understand the
true probability that
something occurred--
whether the true probability
that something occurred was
due to a real difference in
the underlying process or
whether it was just
random chance.
So for example, consider
the following example.
So suppose you're faced with a
professional gambler who told
you that she could get heads
most of the time.
OK, so you might think this is
a reasonable claim or an
unreasonable claim, but this is
what they're claiming and
you want to see if
this is true.
So they toss the coin and
they get heads, right?
So can we learn anything
from that?
Well, probably not because
anyone, even with a fair coin,
50% of the time, they would get
heads if they tossed it.
So we're really can't infer
anything from this one.
What you saw that they did five
times and they got heads,
heads, tails, heads, heads.
Well, can you infer anything
about that?
Well, maybe.
You can start to say, well, this
seems less likely to have
occurred just by
random chance.
But you know there's
only five tosses.
What's the chance that someone
with an even coin
can get four heads?
Well, we could calculate that if
we knew the probabilities.
And it's certainly not
impossible that this could
occur, right?
And now, what if they got
20 tosses, right?
Well, now you're starting to get
information, although in
this particular example,
it was closer to 50-50.
So now you have 12
versus eight.
Could that have occurred
by random chance?
Well, maybe it could
have, right?
Because it's pretty
close to 50-50.
And now, suppose you had 100
tosses or suppose you had
1,000 tosses with 609 heads
and 391 tails, right?
So as you're getting more and
more data, right, you're much
more likely to say something
is meaningful.
So if you saw this data, for
example, the odds that could
occur by random chance
are pretty high.
But if you saw this data with
609 heads and 391 tails out of
1,000 tosses, it's actually
pretty unlikely that this
would occur just by
random chance, OK?
And so this shows you, as you
get more data you can actually
say, how likely was this outcome
to have occurred by
random chance?
And the more data you have, the
more likely you're going
to be able to conclude that
actually, this difference you
observed was actually due to
something that the person was
doing and not just due to what
would happen randomly.
And in some sense, all of
statistics is basically this
intuition, which is, you take
the data you observe and you
calculate what is the chance
that the data I observe could
have occurred just
by random chance.
And if the chance that the data
I observed could have
happened just by random chance
is really unlikely, then you
say, well then it must've been
that your program actually had
an effect, OK?
Does that make sense?
That's the basic idea,
essentially, of all of
statistics is, what's the
probability that this thing
could have happened randomly?
And if it's unlikely, then
probably there was something
else going on.
Here's another example.
So what this example shows is,
now suppose you have a second
gambler who had 1,000 tosses
and they had 530
heads and 470 tails.
What this shows is that-- and
that's really a lot of data.
But in some sense, what we can
learn about this data depends
on what hypothesis we're
interested in.
So if the gambler claimed they
obtained heads 70% of the
time, we could probably say, no,
I don't think so, right?
This is enough data that the
odds that you would get this
data pattern if you had heads
70% of the time are really,
really small, right?
So we could say, I can
reject this claim.
But suppose they said that
they claim they could get
heads 54% of the time, OK?
And you observe they got
heads 53% of the time.
Well, you probably couldn't
reject this claim, right?
Because this is similar enough
to this that if this was the
truth, this could have occurred
by random chance.
So in some sense, what we can
say based on the data depends
on how far the data is from our
hypothesis and how much
data we have.
Does that make sense as
some basic intuition?
OK.
So how do we apply this
to an experiment?
Well, at the end of the
experiment, what we're going
to do is we're going
to compare the
two different groups.
We're going to compare
the treatment
and the control group.
And we're going to say--
we're going to take a look at
the average, just like we were
doing in the gambling example.
We'll compare the average in
the treatment group and the
average in the control, OK?
And the difference is
the effect size.
So for example, in this
particular case, in the
Panchayat case, you'd look at,
for example, the mean number
of wells you've got in the
village with the female
leaders versus the mean number
of wells in the villages with
the male leaders, OK?
So that's in some sense our
estimate of how big the
difference is.
And the question is going to be,
how likely would we have
been to observe this difference
between the
treatment and the control group
if it was just due to
random chance, OK?
And that's what we need the
statistics to figure out.
Now one of the reasons--
so where does the
noise come from?
In some sense, we're not going
to observe an infinite number
of villages.
Or we're not going to observe
all possible villages.
In fact, even if we observe all
the villages that exist,
we're not going to observe,
in some sense, all of the
possible villages that could've
hypothetically
existed if the villages were
replicated millions and
millions of times.
We're just going
to observe some
finite number of villages.
And so we're going to estimate
this mean by computing the
mean in the villages that
we observed, OK?
And if there are very few
villages, that mean that we're
going to calculate is going to
be imprecise because if you
took a different sample of
villages, you would get a
slightly different mean, OK?
If you sample an infinite number
of villages, you get
the same thing every time.
But suppose you only sampled
one village.
Or suppose there was a million
villages out there and you
sampled two, right?
And you took the average, OK?
If you sampled a different two
villages, just by random
chance, you would get
a different average.
And sometimes that's where the
part of the noise in our data
is coming from.
So for example--
sorry.
So in some sense, what we need
to know is, we need to know if
these two groups-- it sort of
goes back to the same as
before, if these two groups were
the same and I sampled
them, what are the chances I
would get the difference that
I observed by random chance?
So for example, suppose
you observed these two
distributions, OK?
So this is your control
group and this is
your treatment group.
Now you can see there is some
noise in the data, right?
This one is a mean of 50 and
this one is a mean of 60.
And there's some--
these are histograms, right?
So this is the distribution of
the number of villages that
you observed for each
possible outcome.
So you can see here that there's
some noise, right?
It's not that everyone here was
exactly 50 and everyone
here was exactly 60.
Some people were 45.
Some were 55 or whatever.
But if you look at these two
distributions, you could say
it's pretty unlikely that if
these were actually drawn from
the same distribution of
villages, all of the blue ones
would be over here and
all the yellow ones
would be over here.
It's very unlikely that if these
were actually the same
and you draw randomly, you get
this real bifurcation of these
villages, OK?
And where are we basing that
idea, that conclusion on?
We're basing the conclusion on
the fact that there's not a
lot of overlap, in some sense,
between these two groups.
But now, what if you saw
this picture, right?
What would you be able
to conclude?
Well, it's a little
less clear.
The mean is still the same.
All the yellows still have an
average of 60 and all the
blues have an average of 50.
But there's a lot more
overlap between them.
Now if we look at this, we can
sort of eyeball it and say,
well, there's really a pretty
big difference even relative
to the distributions there.
So maybe we could conclude that
they were really different.
Maybe not.
And what if we saw
this, right?
This is still the same means.
The yellows have a mean
of 60 and the blues
have a mean of 50.
But now they're so
interspersed that
is harder to know--
it's possible, if you saw
pictures like this, you would
say, well, yes, the yellows are
higher, but maybe this was
just due to random chance, OK?
So what the purpose of these
graphs are, is to show you is
that in order-- so in both
cases, we the same difference
in the mean outcomes.
It was 60 versus 50 in all
three cases, right?
But when you saw this graph, it
was quite clear that these
two groups were really
different.
When you saw this graph, is was
much harder to figure out
if these two were really
different or if this was just
due to random chance, OK?
Does that make sense of
where we're going?
And so, just to come back to
the same theme, all the
statistics are going to do in
our case is going to help us
figure out, are these
differences big enough, given
the distribution of data we
have, how likely is it that
the difference we observed
could have
happened by random chance.
And so intuitively, we can
look at this one and say,
definitely different.
And this one, maybe not sure.
But if we want to be a little
more precise about that,
that's where we need the
added statistics.
AUDIENCE: Is the sample size
the same in both examples?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the sample
size is the same.
Yeah, sample size is
exactly the same.
So you can see that the numbers
go down because it's
more spread out.
All right.
So in some sense, what are the
ingredients that we've talked
about in terms of thinking
about whether you have a
statistically significant
difference?
If you think back to the gambler
example, we talked
about the sample size
matters, right?
So if we saw 1,000 tosses, we
had much more precision about
our estimates than if we had
10 tosses or five tosses.
The hypothesis you're testing
matters, right?
Because the smaller an effect
size we're trying to detect,
the more tosses we need in
the gambler example.
If you're trying to detect a
really small difference, you
need a ton of data, whereas if
you're trying to detect really
extreme differences, you can
do it with less data, OK?
And the third thing we saw is
the variability of the outcome
matters, right?
So the more noisy the outcome
is, the harder it is to know
whether the differences that
we observe are due just to
random chance or if they're
really due some difference in
the treatment versus
the control group.
OK, so does this makes sense?
Before I go on, these are the
three ingredients that we're
going to be playing with.
Do these make sense?
Do you have questions on this?
OK.
So you may have heard of
a confidence interval.
How many of you guys
have heard of
a confidence interval?
OK.
How many of you can state
the definition of
a confidence interval?
Thanks, Dan.
I'm glad that you can.
So what do we mean when we
say confidence interval?
What we mean by a confidence
interval--
so let's just go through what's
on the slide and then
we can talk about it
a little more.
So we're going to measure,
say, 100 people and we're
going to come up with an
average length of 53
centimeters.
So we want to be able to say
something about how precise
our estimate is.
So we say the average
is 53 centimeters.
How confident are we or how
precise are we that it's 53%?
And that's what a conference
interval is trying to say.
And a confidence interval,
essentially, tells us that
with 95% probability--
so we have a confidence interval
of 50-56 says that
with 95% probability, the
true average length lies
between 50 and 56.
And so the precise definition
is that if you had a
hypothesis that the true average
length was in this
range with--
no, I'm going to get it wrong.
It says that if you had a
hypothesis that the true
average was in here, it's within
95% probability that
you would get the data
that you observe, OK?
A converse way of saying it is
that the truth is somewhere in
this range, right?
You can be 95% certain that the
truth is somewhere within
this range, So if you did 20 of
these tests, only one out
of 20 times would the truth
be outside your confidence
interval, OK?
And so an approximate
interpretation of a confidence
interval is--
so we know that the point
estimate of 43, we have some
uncertainty about
that estimate.
We think the average is 53, but
there's some uncertainty.
And the confidence interval
says, well, it's 95% likely
that the true answer is between
50 and 56, if that was
the confidence interval, OK?
So why is that useful for us?
Well, our goal is
to figure out--
we don't care, actually, what
our estimate of the
program's effect is.
We care what the true effect
of a program is, right?
So we did some intervention.
Like, for example, we had a
female Panchayat leader
instead of a male Panchayat
leader and we want to figure
out what the actual difference
that that intervention made is
in the world.
We're going to observe some
sample of Panchayats and we'll
look at the difference
in that sample.
And we want to know how much
can we learn about the true
program effect from
what we estimated.
And the confidence interval
basically tells us that with
95% probability, the true
program effect is somewhere in
the confidence interval, OK?
Does that makes sense?
How many of you guys have heard
of the standard error?
OK.
So a standard error is related
to the confidence interval in
that a standard error says that
if we have some estimate,
you could imagine that if we
did the experiment again,
essentially, with a new sample
of people that looked like the
original sample of people, we
might get a slightly different
point estimate because it's
a different sample.
The standard error basically
says, what's the distribution
of those possible estimates
that you could get, OK?
So it says that basically, if
I did this experiment again,
maybe i wouldn't get
53, I'd get 54.
If I did it again,
maybe I'd get 52.
I might get 53.
The standard error is
essentially the standard
deviation of those possible
estimates that you could get.
What that means in practice
is that--
well, in practice, the standard
error is very related
to the confidence interval.
And basically, a good rule of
thumb is that a 95% confidence
interval is about two
standard errors.
So if you ever see an estimate
of the standard error, you can
calculate the confidence
interval, essentially, by
going up or down two standard
errors from the point
estimate, OK?
And the confidence interval
and standard error,
essentially, are capturing
the same thing.
They're both capturing--
when I said we need statistics
to basically compute, how
likely is it that we would get
these differences by random
chance, those are all coming out
in the standard error and
the confidence interval,
right?
They're computed by both looking
at how noisy our data
is, which is the variability
of the outcome, and how big
our sample is, right?
Because from these two things,
you can basically calculate
how uncertain your estimate
would be.
This is a lot of terminology
very quickly, but does this
all make sense?
Any questions on this?
OK.
So for example.
So suppose we saw the sampled
women Pradhans had 7.13 years
of education and the men had
9.92 years of education, OK?
And you want to know, is the
truth that men have more
education than women or is this
just a random artifact of
our sample?
So suppose you calculated that
the difference was 2.59.
That's easy to calculate.
And the standard error was 0.54
and the standard error
was going to be calculated based
on both how much data
you had and how noisy
the data was.
You would compute that the 95%
confidence interval is between
1.53 and 3.64, OK?
So this means that with 95%
probability, the true
difference in education rates
between men and women is
between 1.53 and 3.64.
So if you were interested in
testing the hypothesis that,
in fact, men and women are the
same in education, you could
say that I can reject
that hypothesis.
With 95% probability, the
true difference is
between 1.53 and 3.64--
so zero is not in this
confidence interval, right?
So we can reject the hypothesis
that there's no
difference between
these two groups.
Does that makes sense?
So doing another example.
So in this example, suppose
that we saw that control
children had an average test
score of 2.45 and the
treatment had an average
test score of 2.5.
So we saw a difference of
0.05 and the standard
error was 0.26, OK?
So in this case, you would say
well, the 95% confidence
interval is minus 0.55.
This is approximately two.
It's not exactly two.
Minus 0.55--
oh, no, it is exactly
two in this example.
Minus 0.55 to 0.46, OK?
And here, you would say that
if we were introducing the
hypothesis that the null
hypothesis is that the
treatment had no effect on test
scores, you could not
reject that null hypothesis,
right?
Because an effect of zero
is within the confidence
interval, OK?
So that's basically how we
use confidence intervals.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't the two
points of that confidence
interval be equidistant
from 2.59?
PROFESSOR: From 0.05 you mean?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I think--
oh, over here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So they actually
don't always have--
so you raise a good point.
So there may be some
math errors here.
I think a more reasonable
estimate, by the way, is that
this would have to be minus
0.05 for you to get
something like this.
AUDIENCE: But in the first
example, if 2.59 is the mean,
is the difference--
PROFESSOR: So it's
approximately
the same, isn't it?
AUDIENCE: I think it's
a little skewed--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: On that side,
it is 2.64.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah, so you raise
a good point.
So when I said that a rule
of thumb is two times the
standard error, that's
a rule of thumb.
And in particular cases, you can
sometimes get asymmetric
confidence intervals.
So you're right that usually
they should be symmetric and
probably, for simplicity, we
should have put up symmetric
ones, but it can occur that
confidence intervals are
asymmetric.
For example, if you had a--
yeah, depending on the
estimation, if you have
truncation at zero--
if you know for sure that there
can never be an outcome
below zero, for example, then
you can get asymmetric
confidence intervals.
AUDIENCE: When the distribution
is not normal?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Exactly.
But for most things that you'll
be investigating,
usually they're going to be--
AUDIENCE: Normal.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, for outcomes
that are zero.
One [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
get non-normal, but
yes, in general,
they are pretty symmetric.
But they might not be
exactly symmetric.
OK.
So as I sort of was suggesting
as we were going through these
examples, we're often interested
in testing the
hypothesis that the effect size
is equal to zero, right?
The classic hypothesis the you
typically want to know is, did
my program do anything, right?
And so, how do you test the
hypothesis that my program--
so we want to know, did
my program have
any effect at all?
And so what we technically want
to do is we want to test
what's called the null
hypothesis, that the program
had an effect of nothing,
against an alternative
hypothesis that the program
had some effect.
So this is the typical test
that we want to do.
Now you could say, actually,
I don't care about zero.
I want to say that I know--
for example, this is the
standard thing that we would do
in most policy evaluations
that we're going to be doing.
It doesn't have to be zero.
Suppose you were doing a drug
trial and you knew that the
best existing treatment
out there already have
an effect of one.
And so instead of comparing
to zero, you might be
comparing to one.
Is it actually better than the
best existing treatment?
In most cases, we're usually
comparing to zero, OK?
And usually, we have the
alternative hypothesis that
the effect is just not zero.
We're interested in anything
other than zero.
Sometimes you can specify other
alternative hypotheses,
that the effect is always
positive or always negative,
but usually this is the classic
case, which is we're
saying, we think this thing
had-- the null is no effect.
We want to say, did this program
have an effect and
we're interested in any
possible effect, OK?
And hypothesis testing says,
when can I reject this null
hypothesis in favor of
this alternative, OK?
And as we saw, essentially,
the confidence interval is
giving you a way to do that.
It's saying, if the null is
outside the confidence
interval, then I can
reject the null.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Surely, if we're
trying to assess the impact of
an intervention, we're always
going to think it's positive.
Or in general, because--
I gave someone some money to
increase their income or not.
We've got a pretty good idea
it's going to be positive.
The probability it's negative
is pretty--
PROFESSOR: Why do you--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, why
do we change our
significance level--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: You ask
a great question.
And I have to say this is
a bit of a source of
frustration of mine.
Let me give you a couple
different answers to that.
Here's the thing.
If you did that--
if I said I can commit, before
I look at the data, that I
only think it could be positive,
that would mean that
if it's negative, no matter how
negative, you're going to
say that was random
chance, OK?
So it would require a fair
amount of commitment on you,
on your part, as the
experimenter to say, if I get
a negative result, no matter how
crazy that negative result
is, I'm going to say that's
random chance, OK?
And typically, what often
happens ex post is that people
can't commit to actually
doing that.
So suppose you did your
program and you--
so I actually have a program
right now that I'm working on
in Indonesia that's supposed to
improve health and education.
And it seems to be making
education worse.
Now, we have no theory for why
this program should be making
education worse, OK?
But it certainly seems to
be there in the data.
Now, if we had adopted your
approach, we wouldn't be
entertaining the hypothesis that
it made education worse.
We would say, even though it's
looking like this program is
making education worse,
that must be random
noise in the data.
We're not going to treat that as
something potentially real.
Ex post, though, you see this in
the data and you're likely
to say, gee, man, that's a
really negative effect.
Maybe the program was doing
something that I
didn't think about.
And in our case, actually, we're
starting to investigate
and maybe it's because it was
health and education and we're
sort of sucking resources away
from education into health.
So it requires a lot of
commitment on your part, as
the researcher, that if you get
these negative effects, to
treat them as random noise.
And I think that, because most
researchers, even though they
would like to say they're
going to do that, if it
happens that they get a really
negative effect, they're going
to want to say, gee, that looks
like a negative effect.
We're going to want
to investigate
that, take that seriously.
Because most people do that ex
post, the convention is that
in most cases, to say we're
going to test against either
hypothesis in either
direction.
AUDIENCE: Except that
the approach--
PROFESSOR: Does that
makes sense?
AUDIENCE: Your issue is do
I do this program or not.
So it doesn't matter whether the
impact of the program is
zero or negative.
Even if it's zero, you're
saying that it's--
PROFESSOR: You're absolutely
right.
So if you were strict about it
and said, I'm going to do it
if it's positive and not if it's
zero, then I think you
were correct that, strictly
speaking, a one-sided
hypothesis test will be correct
and it would give you
some more power.
AUDIENCE: So it would
give you power.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it would
give you more power.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
And the reason it gives you
power is, remember, how does
hypothesis testing work?
It says, well, what is the
chance this outcome could have
occurred 95--
what would have occurred by
chance 95% of the time?
When you do a two-sided
test, you say, OK--
where's my chalkboard?
Here.
You imagine a normal
distribution of outcomes.
You're going to say, well, the
95% is in the middle and
anything in the tails is the
stuff that I'm going to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] by
non-random chance.
Well, what you're doing with a
one-sided test is you're going
to say, I'm going to take
that negative stuff--
way out there negative stuff--
and I'm going to say that's
also random chance.
So I'm going to pick my 95%
all the way to the left.
And that means that the 5%
that's not random chance is a
little more to the right.
Do you see what I'm saying?
But it requires that if--
you're committing to, even if
you get really negative
outcomes, asserting that they're
random chance, which
is really, often, kind
of unbelievable.
The other thing is that,
although this is technically
the way hypothesis testing
is set up, the norms and
conventions are that we all use
two-sided tests for these
reasons I talked about.
And so I can just tell you that,
practically speaking, I
think if you do a one-sided
test, people are going to be
skeptical because it may be that
you, actually, would do
that, but I think most of
the time, people can't
commit to do that.
And so the standard has become
two-sided tests.
But I certainly agree
with you.
It's very frustrating because
one should be able to
articulate one-sided
hypotheses.
That's sort of a long answer,
but does that make sense?
It's OK.
OK, now, for those of you on
this side of the board, you
won't be able to see, but
maybe if I need to write
something on the board
it will be better.
OK.
So now we're going to talk
about type I and type II
errors, which, as I mentioned,
are not helpfully named.
OK.
A type I error--
so this is all about
probability, so nothing we can
ever say for sure.
We can always say that this
is more or less likely.
And there's two different types
of errors we can make
when we're doing these
probabilities or doing these
assessments.
The first error, and it's called
type I error, is we can
conclude that there was an
effect when, in fact, there
was no effect, OK?
So when I said the 95%
confidence interval, that 95%
is coming from our choice
about type 1 errors.
So for example--
a significance level is the
probability that you're going
to falsely conclude the program
had an effect when, in
fact, there was no effect, OK?
And that's related to when you
say a 95% confidence interval,
the remaining 5% is what we're
talking about here.
That's the probability of making
a type I error, OK?
And why is that?
Well, we said there's a 95%
chance that it's going to be
within this range.
That means that just by random
chance, there's some chance it
could be outside that
range, right?
So if your confidence interval
was over here and zero was
over here, you would say, well,
with 95% conference, I'm
going to assume the program had
an effect because zero is
not within my confidence
interval.
However, 5% of the time, the
true effect could be over here
outside your confidence
interval.
That's what a 95% confidence
interval means.
So in some sense, that's
what we mean by a--
so that's in some sense what
a type I error is.
A type I error is the
probability that you're going
to detect an effect when,
in fact, there's not.
And so the typical levels that
you may see are 5%, 1% or 10%
significance levels.
And the way to think about those
significance levels is,
if you see something that's
significant at the 10% level,
that means it 10% of the time,
an effect of that size
could've been just due
to random chance.
Might not actually
be a true effect.
And if you've heard of a
p-value, a p-value is exactly
this number.
A p-value basically says, what
is the probability that an
effect this size or larger could
have occurred just by
random chance, OK?
So that's what's called
a type I error.
And typically, there's no deep
reason why 5% is the normal
level of type I errors that we
use, but it's kind of the
convention.
It's what everyone else uses.
If you use something different,
people are going to
look at you a little funny.
So the conventions are we have
5%, 10%, and 1%, as these
significance levels.
And you might say, gee, 5%
or 10% seems pretty low.
Maybe I would want
a bigger one.
But on the other hand, if you
start thinking about it, that
means that if you use 10%
significance, that means that
one out of every 10 studies
is going to be wrong.
Or if you had 10 different
outcomes in your data set, one
out of every 10 would be
significant even just by
random chance.
So the other type of error is
what's called, as I said,
helpfully, a type II error.
And a type II error says that
you fail to reject that the
program had no effect when, in
fact, there was an effect, OK?
So this is, the program did
something, but I can't pick it
up in the data, OK?
And we talk about the
power of a test.
The power is basically the
opposite of a type II error.
A power just says, what's the
probability that I will be
able to find an effect
given that the actual
effect is there, OK?
So when we talk about how big
a sample size we need, what
we're basically talking about
is, how much power are we
going to have to detect
an effect?
Or what's the probability that
given that a true effect is
there, we're going to pick
it up in the data, OK?
So here's an example of how
to think about power.
If I ran the experiment 100
times-- not 100 samples, but
if I ran the whole
thing 100 times--
what percentage of the time and
in how many these cases
would I be able to say, reject
the hypothesis that men and
women have the same education
at the 5% level if, in fact,
they're different, OK?
So this is a helpful graph
which basically plots the
truth and what you're going
to conclude based
on your data, OK?
So suppose the truth is that
you had no effect and you
conclude your no effect, OK?
Then you're happy.
If there was an effect and you
conclude there was an effect,
you're happy.
So you want to be in one
of these two boxes.
And the two types of errors you
can make-- so one type of
error is over here, right?
So if the truth is there was no
effect, but you concluded
there was an effect, that
would be making a
type I error, OK?
And this is what we
talked about size.
So this one, we normally
fix this one at 5%.
So it's only 5% of the time--
if there's no effect, 5% of the
time you're going to end
up here and 95% of the time
you're going to end up here.
That's what a 95% confidence
interval is telling you.
And the other thing is, suppose
that the thing had an
effect but you couldn't find
it in the data, OK?
That's what's called
a type II error.
And that's, when we design our
experiments, we want to make
sure that our samples are
sufficiently large that the
probability you end up in this
box is not too big, OK?
So that's a sense of what we
mean by the different types of
mistakes or errors
you could make.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's kind of
a stupid question.
So power is the probability
that you are not
making a type II error?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So then power is the
probability that you're in the
smiley face box,
that you are--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Power is the probability
you're over here.
Yeah, we say power is related
to type II errors.
Power is over here.
This is the power.
Power is conditional on
there being an effect.
What's the probability you're
in this box, not this box?
Probably should say one minus
power to be clearer.
OK?
Does that makes sense?
All right.
So when we're designing
experiments, we typically fix
this at conventional levels.
And we choose our sample size
so that we get this, the
power, or the probability that
you're in the happy face box
over here to a reasonable level
given the effect size
that we think we're
likely to get, OK?
OK.
Now, in some sense, the next two
things, standard errors,
are about this box, size.
And power is about this
box, or these boxes.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why is power not also
the probability that you
end up in the bottom right box
as opposed to the bottom left?
PROFESSOR: Because
that's size.
AUDIENCE: Isn't size also linked
to-- or power also
linked to--
PROFESSOR: No, they're all
related, but we typically--
they're related in the
following way.
We assert a size because when
we calculate our standard
error-- our confidence
intervals, we pick how big or
small we want the confidence
intervals to be.
When we say a 95% confidence
interval, we're
picking the size, OK?
So this one, we get to choose.
AUDIENCE: So it's not sample
size, it's size of the
confidence interval?
PROFESSOR: No.
Yeah, this is size is a--
yeah, it's the size of the
confidence interval.
That's right.
Sorry, it's not the
sample size.
That's right.
It's called the size of the
test in yet more confusing
terminology.
That's right.
This is the size of the
confidence interval,
essentially.
And this one you pick,
and this one is
determined by your data.
OK?
All right.
OK, so now let's talk about this
part, which is standard
errors and significance.
It's all kind of related.
All right, so we're going
to estimate the
effect of our program.
And we typically call that
beta, or beta hat.
So the convention is that things
that are estimated, we
put a little hat
over them, OK?
So beta hat is going to be our
estimate of the program's
effectiveness.
This is our best guess as to the
difference between these
two groups.
So for example, this is the
average treatment test score
minus the average control
test score.
And then we're also going to
calculate our estimate of the
standard error of
beta hat, right?
And remember that the confidence
interval is about
two times the standard error.
So the standard error is going
to say how precise our
estimate of beta hat is, which
is, remember, if we ran the
experiment 100 times, what will
be the distributions of
beta hats that we
would get, OK?
And this depends on the sample
size and the noise in the
data, right?
And remember we went through
this already that here, in
this case, the standard error of
how confident we would be--
so the beta hat, in this case,
is going to be 10, and in this
case, it's also going
to be 10, right?
But here, these two things are
really precisely estimated, so
our standard error of beta hat
is going to be very small
because we're going to say we
have a very precise estimate
of the difference
between them.
And so the confidence
interval is also
going to be very small.
And here, there's lots of noise
in the data, so our
estimate of the standard error
is going to be larger.
So in both cases, beta
hat is the same.
It's 10 in both cases.
But the standard error
is very big here and
very small here, OK?
Now, when we calculate the
statistical significance, we
use something called
a t-ratio.
And the t-ratio--
it's actually often called the
student's t-ratio, which I
thought was because
students used it.
But it's actually named
after Mr. Student.
It's the ratio of beta hat
to the standard error
of beta hat, OK?
And the reason that we happen to
use this ratio is that, if
there is no effect, if beta hat
is actually zero, we know
that this thing has a normal
distribution, so we can
calculate the probabilities that
this thing is really or
really small, OK?
So we calculate this ratio of
beta hat over the standard
error of beta hat.
It turns out that
if t is greater
than, in absolute value--
sorry, if the absolute value of
t, I should say, is greater
than 1.96--
so essentially, if it's bigger
than 2 or less than minus 2,
we're going to reject the
hypothesis of a quality at a
5% significance level.
And why is that?
It's because it turns out, from
statistics, that if the
truth is zero, OK?
So if we're in the no effect
box and the truth is zero,
this ratio, it turns out, will
have a normal distribution.
And it just turns out from a
normal distribution that the
probability that the 5%
confidence interval is 1.96
away from zero if you have
a normal distribution.
That's just a fact about normal
distributions, OK?
So if we calculate this ratio
and we say it's greater in
absolute value than 1.96, we're
going to reject the
hypothesis of a quality
at the 5% level, OK?
So we can reject zero.
Zero is going to be outside of
our confidence interval.
And if it's less than 1.96,
we're going to fail to reject
it because zero is going to
be inside our confidence
interval, OK?
So in this case, for example,
the difference was 2.59.
The standard error was 0.54.
The t-ratio is about seven.
No, it's about five.
So we're definitely going
to be able to
reject in this case.
So we have a t-ratio
of about five, OK?
So you may see this terminology
and this is where
it's coming from.
Now, there's an important point
to note here, which will
come up later when we talk
about power calculations,
which is, in some sense, that
the power that we have is
determined by this ratio of
the point estimate to our
standard error.
And so this says, for example,
that if we kind of look at
this a little more, that if you
have bigger betas, you can
still detect effects for
a given standard--
so if you fix the standard
error but you made beta
bigger, you're more likely
to conclude there was a
difference, right?
So what's going to increase your
being able to conclude
there was a difference?
Either your effect size is
bigger or your standard error
is smaller, mechanically.
OK.
So that's how we are going to
calculate being in this box.
So how do we think about
power, which is the
probability that we're
in this box?
We had an effect and we're able
to detect that-- sorry,
power's in this box-- that
we had an effect, OK?
So when we're planning an
experiment, we can do some
calculations to help us figure
out what that power is.
What's the probability, if the
truth is a certain level, that
we're going to be able to
pick it up in the data?
And what do we need
to do that?
We're going to have to specify
a null hypothesis, which is
usually zero.
We're going to be testing that
something's different than
zero, the two groups are
the same, for example.
We're going to have to pick our
significance level, our size.
And that, we almost
always pick at 5%.
We're going to have to
pick an effect size.
And we'll talk about what
exactly this means in a couple
more slides.
But when we calculate a power,
a power is for a given
effect size, OK?
And then we'll calculate
the power.
So for example, suppose
that we did this
and a power was 80%.
That would mean that if we did
this experiment 100 times--
not 100 times, but actually
repeated the whole experiment
100 times, 80% of the times we
did this experiment, if the
hypothesis is, in fact, false,
and instead, the truth is
this, we would be able to reject
the null and conclude
there was a true effect
80% of the time, OK?
That's a little bit complicated,
but does that
make sense, what we're going to
be trying to do with power?
So we're going to fix
the effect size.
So remember, we fix
the bottom box.
When we calculate power, we
have to speculate not just
effect versus no effect.
We have to postulate just how
effective the program is.
So we're going to say, suppose
that the effect size is 5%.
The truth is 0.2, right?
How big a sample would we need
to be in this box 80%
of the time, OK?
So when we say power,
that's what we mean.
And when we calculate the size
of the experiments, you have
to make a judgment call of how
big a power do you want.
The typical powers that we use
when we do power calculations,
are either 80% or 90%.
So what does this mean?
This means-- suppose
you did 80%.
Or [UNINTELLIGIBLE] this.
If you did 80%, that would
mean that if you ran your
experiment 100 times and the
true effect was 0.2 in this
case, you would be able
to pick up an effect,
statistically 80 out
of those 100 times.
20 out of 100 times,
you wouldn't.
And the bigger your sample size,
the larger your power is
going to be, OK?
Does that make sense so far?
OK.
Suppose you wanted to calculate
what our power is
going to be.
What are the things you
would need to know?
You would need to know
your significance
level of your size.
And as I said, this,
we just assume, OK?
This is that bottom box.
We're just going to assume
that it's 5%.
And the lower it is,
the larger sample
you're going to need.
But this one is sort
of picked for you.
We almost always use 5% because
that's the convention.
That's what everyone
uses, essentially.
The second thing you need to
know is the mean and the
variance of the outcome in
the comparison group.
So you need to know--
so remember, all this power
calculation is going to depend
on whether your sample looks
like this, really tight, or
looks like this and
is very noisy.
Because you obviously
need a much bigger
sample here than here.
So in order to do a power
calculation, you need to know,
well, just what does the outcome
look like, right?
Does the outcome really have
very narrow variance?
Is everyone almost exactly the
same, in which case it's going
to be very easy to
detect effects?
Or is there are huge range of
people, in which case you're
going to need bigger effects.
Now, how do we get this?
So this one, we just
conventionally set.
This one, we have to
get somewhere.
And we usually have to get it
from some other survey.
So we have to find someone
that collected data in a
similar population.
Or sometimes we'll go and
collect data ourselves in that
same population.
Just a very small survey just
to get a sense of what this
variable looks like, OK?
And if the variability is big,
we're going to need a really
big sample.
And if the variability is really
small, we're going to
need a small sample.
And it's really important to do
this because you don't want
to spend all your time and money
running an experiment
only to turn out that there was
no hope of ever finding an
effect because the power
was too small, right?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And this is in the
entire population, not just
the comparison group, right?
It says-- --
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but before
you do your treatment, the
comparison and the treatment
are the same.
AUDIENCE: They are the same.
PROFESSOR: Doesn't matter.
AUDIENCE: So it's a baseline
population.
PROFESSOR: Baseline
would be fine.
Yeah.
Before you do your treatment,
they're the same.
So it doesn't matter, OK?
And the first thing you need
is, you need to make an
assumption about what effect
size you want to detect.
And this one--
sometimes you also have
to supply this.
And the best way to think about
what effect size you
want to put in here is you
want to say, what's the
smallest effect that would
prompt a policy response, OK?
So one could think about this,
for example, by doing a
cost-benefit calculation,
right?
You could say that we do a
cost-benefit calculation.
This thing costs $100.
If we don't get an effective
0.1, it's just
not worth $100, right?
So that would be a good way of
coming up with how big an
effect size you want here.
And the idea, then, is if the
effect is any smaller than
this, it's just not interesting
to distinguish it
from zero, right?
Suppose that the thing had a
true effect of 0.001, right?
But if it was that small of an
effect, it could be completely
cost effective.
So say the thing happens
at an effect of 0.001.
Who cares, right?
So you want to be thinking
about, from a policy
perspective is, what's the
smallest effect size you want
to know, from a policy
perspective, in order to set
your power calculations?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
back at the mean
and variance thing.
PROFESSOR: Oh, here.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So in terms of the baseline
thing that you would collect--
so I'm on the implementation
side of this, right?
So we do projects.
We collect baseline data.
Now, the case that I'm thinking
of, the baseline data
that we would collect might not
be exactly the same kind
of data that we are looking
for in terms of our study.
What kind of base-- how--
PROFESSOR: Right, OK.
So when we say baseline, there's
two different things
we mean by baseline.
For this case, this is not
strictly a baseline.
This is just something about
what's your variable
going to look like.
Let me come back to
that in a sec.
We also sometimes talk about
baselines that we are going to
use of actually collecting the
actual outcome variable before
we start the intervention,
right?
Those are also useful, and we'll
talk about those in a
couple slides.
And those, one wants them to be
more similar, probably, to
the actual variable you're
going to use.
Now, for your case,
we often don't--
the accuracy of your power
calculation depends pretty
critically on how close this
mean and variance are to what
you're going to actually
get in your data.
And when you start in the
example that you guys are
going to work on or that maybe
you've already started working
on, you're going to
find that it's
actually pretty sensitive.
Turns out it's pretty
sensitive.
So getting these wrong is
going to mean your power
calculation is going
to be wrong.
So that's sort of an argument
for saying you want this to be
as good as possible.
Now the flip side of that,
though, is you're going to
find that these power
calculations are fairly
sensitive to what effect size
you choose as well.
So you're going to find that if
you go from a effect size
of 0.2 to an effect size of 0.1,
you're going to need four
times the sample.
That's just the way the
math works out.
By which I'm going to mean that
I think that these power
calculations are useful for
making sure you're in the
right ballpark, but not
necessarily going to nail an
exact number for you.
All that's by way of saying that
you want to get-- because
these things are so sensitive,
you want to get as close as
possible to what's actually
going to be there.
On the other hand you're going
to find the results are also
so sensitive to the effect size
you want to detect that
if this was a little bit off,
that might be a tradeoff you
would be willing to live
with in practice.
AUDIENCE: So, from my--
PROFESSOR: Does that
make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but it seems
like the effect size-- your
estimate of your effect
size is this kind of--
we've got all this science for
the calculation and yet your
estimate of your effect
size is based on--
PROFESSOR: You're absolutely
right.
AUDIENCE: --getting that--
PROFESSOR: Hold on, though.
Let me back up a little
bit, though.
You're right, except the--
in some sense, the best way to
get estimates for your effect
size is to look at similar
programs, OK?
So now there are lots
of programs in
education, for example.
And they tend to find effect--
I've now seen a bazillion things
that work on improving
test scores.
And I can tell you that
they tend to get--
standardized effect size is the
effect size divided by the
standard deviation.
And they tend to get effect
sizes in the 0.1, 0.15, 0.2
range, right?
So you can look at those and
say, well, I think that most
other comparable interventions
are getting 0.1, so I'm going
to use 0.1 as my effect size.
So you're right if you're
just trying to sit here
introspectful--
what my effect size is going
to be, it's very hard.
But if you use comparable
studies to get a sense, then
you can get a sense.
And the other thing I mentioned
is, you can do
cost-benefit analysis and
say, well, look--
which is sort of another way
of saying it, If there are
other things out there which
cost $100 per kid and get 0.1,
then my thing, presumably, has
got to do at least as well as
0.1 for $100-- suppose the other
thing also costs $100 a
kid, I've got to do at
last as well as 0.1.
Otherwise, I'd rather
do this other thing.
So it's another way of getting
at the effect size.
AUDIENCE: Could you, then, also
look at existing data in
the literature for the mean
and variance thing,
or do you have to--
PROFESSOR: You could, but this
one is going to be more
sensitive to your population.
AUDIENCE: So it would just have
to be very well-matched
to be able to use it.
PROFESSOR: Right.
I mean, look, if you don't have
it, you could do it to
get a sense, but this is
one where the different
populations are going to be
very different in terms of
their mean and variance.
In order to get an estimate of
this, you need a much, much,
much smaller sample size than
you need to get an estimate of
the overall treatment effect
of the program.
So you can often do
a small survey--
much, much, smaller than your
big survey, but a small survey
just to get a sense of what
these things look like.
And that can often be a very
worthwhile thing to do.
AUDIENCE: I have a
related question.
How often do you see--
PROFESSOR: Oh, sorry.
I just wanted to do one
other thing on this.
I've had this come up in my
own experience, where I've
done this small survey, and
found that the baseline
situation was such that
the whole experiment
didn't make any sense.
And we just canceled
the experiment.
And it can be really useful.
If you say, if I do this and
my power is 0.01, for
reasonable effect sizes,
this is pointless.
So it can be worth it.
Sorry.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So to estimate the
effect size, have you seen
people run small pilots in
different populations than
they're eventually going to do
their impact evaluation to get
a sense of what effect size are
they seeing with that same
intervention?
PROFESSOR: Not usually, because
you can't do a small
pilot to get the effect
size, right?
AUDIENCE: You're going
to see something--
PROFESSOR: You've got to
do the whole thing.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
PROFESSOR: Right?
That's the whole point of the
power calculations is, in
order to detect an effect of
that size, you need to do the
whole sample.
So a small pilot won't
really do it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: So it's not really
going to-- you could get a--
no, I guess you really can't get
a sense because you would
need the whole experiment to
detect the effect size.
AUDIENCE: Don't you think that
there should be a lot more
conversation about effect size
before things start?
Because if you've got a
treatment, if you've got a
program, and you can't have a
very-- and you've struggled to
have a good conversation about
what is actually going to
happen to the kids or what's
going to happen to the health
or what's going to happen to
the income as a result of
this, it really may be quite
telling that you really don't
know what you're doing.
That there isn't enough of
a theory behind your-- or
practice or science or anything
behind what your
program is.
If people are not pretty
sure, what--
PROFESSOR: I mean,
yes and no--
AUDIENCE: And then, also, on
the resource allocation.
Resource allocation, it just
seems to me, most of the time,
if your ultimate client
is really probably the
government, right?
Because the government is the
one that's going to make the
big resource allocations--
PROFESSOR: It depends on who
you're working with.
It could be an NGO, whoever.
But yes.
AUDIENCE: No, but an NGO is
doing something, usually, as a
demonstration that, in fact,
if it works, then the
government should do it.
PROFESSOR: Not always, but
there's someone who,
presumably, is going
to scale up.
AUDIENCE: Right.
And yes, businesses,
maybe, right?
But I would say, 90% of the
time, it's going to be,
ultimately, the government
needs to--
PROFESSOR: Often, it's
the government.
In India, for example, there
are NGOs who are--
I don't know who's worked on
the Pratham reading thing.
They're trying to teach--
NGOs trying to teach millions
of kids to read, as an NGO.
So sometimes NGOs
scale up too.
But anyway, you're right that
there's an ultimate client
who's interested in this.
AUDIENCE: So then, having
a conversation
very early on about--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Could be very useful.
That's absolutely right.
AUDIENCE: Because--
PROFESSOR: Now, in terms of
your point about theory,
though, yes and no.
So I can design an experiment
that's supposed to teach kids
how to read.
I know the theory says it should
affect reading but I
have no idea how much.
And so--
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't you say that
a significant percentage
of the time, if it's a good
theory about reading, it
actually should tell you?
PROFESSOR: Not always.
I mean--
AUDIENCE: Well, then I'd
say it's not such a
great theory, right?
Wouldn't you--
PROFESSOR: It's a little bit
semantic, but I think that a
lot of times, I can--
say I'm going to teach kids to
read a paragraph or whatever.
But what percentage of the kids
is it going to work for?
What percentage of the kids
are going to be affected?
I think that using theory
to calculate how--
I think theory can tell
you a lot what
variables should be affected.
And that's what we talked about
in the last lecture.
I think theory can tell you what
the sign of those effects
likely to be.
I think it's often putting a lot
of demands on your theory
to have them tell you
the magnitude.
And that's why you want
to do the experiment.
AUDIENCE: And you just told me
that even beyond the theory,
you say, well, but we did this
in one school and we saw it
had this great thing,
but you're saying--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: But your confidence
interval is going to be--
well, it's not nothing.
It's going to tell you
something, but your confidence
interval is going
to be enormous.
AUDIENCE: Right, nothing
that you could
rely on to set a good--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Right, it gives you
a data point, but it's going
to have a huge conference
interval.
AUDIENCE: I don't want to
belabor this, but if you think
about it in business
terms, right?
I want to go out and
raise some money.
PROFESSOR: Yes, absolutely.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --something.
And so, in order to raise that
money, I have to tell you
that, in fact, you're going
to make this much money.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: And, of course, it
could turn out to be wrong.
But I have to tell you you're
going to get a 25% return on
your money.
And that means I have to
explain to you why this
business is going to successful,
how many people
are going to buy it, how I'm
going to manage my costs down.
So it's always curious to me
that, when you're talking
about social interventions, that
I'm not having to make
that same argument with that
same level of specificity,
which means I've talked
about the effect size.
Because I can't raise money if I
tell you, look, I might only
make you 5% or we might shoot
the moon and make 100%.
You'll say, thank
you very much.
This person doesn't know
what their business is.
I'm not going to give
them my money.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you actually hit on exactly
what's on the next slide.
Which is exactly what I was
going to say, which is, what
you want to think about with
your effect size is exactly
this thing.
What's the cost of this
program versus
the benefit it brings?
And sometimes, what's the cost
vis-a-vis alternative uses of
the money, right?
And that's going to be a
conversation you're going to
have with your client, which is
going to say, if the effect
size was 0.1, I would do it.
And then you say, OK, I'm going
to design an experiment
to see if it's 0.1
or bigger, right?
So I'm totally on
board with that.
Because, as I was saying, if
the effect size is smaller
than that, it still could be
positive, but if your client
doesn't care, if it's not worth
the money at that level,
then why do we need to design
a big experiment
to pick that up?
It's also worth noting this
is not your expected
effect size, right?
I could expect this thing to
have an effect of 0.2 but even
if it was as low as 0.1,
it would still be
worth doing, OK?
And in that case, I might want
to design an experiment of
0.1, right?
Conversely, you guys can all
imagine the opposite, which is
you could say, I expect
this thing to be 0.1,
but maybe it's 0.2.
Maybe it's actually--
I'm not sure how good it is.
I think it's OK.
But maybe it could
be really great.
And if it was really great, I
would want to adopt it, so I
would design an experiment
to 0.2.
So it's not the expected effect
size, it's what you
would use to adopt
the program.
When we talk about
effect sizes, we
often talk about them--
we talk about what we call
standardized effect size, OK?
As I mentioned, how large an
effect you can detect depends
on how variable your
sample is.
So if everyone's the
same, it's very
easy to pick up effects.
And we often talk about
standardized effects are the
effect size divided by the
standard deviation of the
outcome, OK?
So standard deviation of outcome
is the measure of how
variable your outcome is.
So we often express our effect
sizes relative to the standard
deviation of the outcome, OK?
And so when I was talking
about test scores, for
example, test scores are usually
normalized to have a
standard deviation of one.
So this is actually how we
normally express things in
terms of test scores, but we
could do it for anything.
And so effect sizes of
0.1, 0.2 are small.
0.4 are medium.
0.5 are large.
Now what do we mean by that?
This is actually a very helpful
way of thinking about
what a standardized effect
size is telling you.
So a standardized effect size of
0.2, which is what we were
saying was a modest one, means
that the average person in the
treatment group, the median
or the mean person of the
treatment group, had a better
outcome than 58% of the people
in the control group.
So remember, if it was zero,
it would be 50-50.
It would be 50%, right?
If there was no effect, the
distributions would line up
and this person's in the
treatment group--
the median person in the
treatment group would be
better than 50% of the people
in the control group.
So this is saying, instead of
lining up at exactly 50-50,
it's lining up 58%-50%, OK?
If you get an effect size of
0.5, which we were saying was
a large effect, that means that
69% of the people in the
treatment group are going to
be bigger than the median
person in the control group.
Sorry, it's the other
way around.
The average member of the
intervention group is better
than 69% of people in
the control group.
So the distributions are
still overlapping.
But now there's--
the middle of the treatment
distribution is at the 69th
percentile of the control.
And a large effect of 0.8 would
mean that the median
person in the treatment group
is at the 79th percentile of
the control.
That just gives you a sense of
when we're talking about
standardized effect sizes, how
big we're talking about.
And so you can see that
0.2, is actually--
you can imagine is going to be
pretty hard to detect, right?
If the median person in the
treatment group looks like the
58th percentile of the control
group, that's going to be a
case where those distributions
have a lot of overlap, right?
And so this is going to be much
harder to detect than
this case when the overlap
is much smaller.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So in your experience,
what do most
people think their
effect size is?
Where do they settle?
They probably wouldn't
settle at 0.2?
PROFESSOR: Actually, a lot of
people in a lot of educational
interventions--
AUDIENCE: That's enough
for them?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I would say the typical
intervention that people study
that I've seen in education,
the effect size is in the
0.15, 0.2 range.
It turns out it's really hard
to move test scores.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So yeah, I
would say a lot of--
but you'll see when you do the
power calculations, that to
detect 0.2, you often need
a pretty big sample.
Look, it depends a lot on what
your intervention is, but I've
seen a lot in that range.
And I'm just trying to think
of an experiment I did.
I can't think of it off hand.
But yeah, I would say
a lot in this range.
AUDIENCE: So would the converse
be true, that in
fact, you don't see too
many that have a real
large effect size?
PROFESSOR: I would say it's
pretty rare that I see
interventions that are 0.8.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you think it's
valuable that just because
you're setting a low effect
size in designing your
experiment, you're being
conservative.
You can still pick up a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] effect size--
PROFESSOR: Of course.
AUDIENCE: It's just in
the design process--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Right.
This is the minimum thing
you could pick up.
That's absolutely right.
That's right.
So right, if you design for 0.2
but, in fact, your thing
is amazing and does 0.8, well,
there's no problem at all.
You'll have a p-value
of 0.00 something.
You'll have a very strong
[INAUDIBLE].
It's a good point.
OK.
So how do we actually
calculate our power?
So there's actually a very nice
software package, which,
have you guys started
using this yet?
Yeah?
OK.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Can you just clarify something
before you go on?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So by rejecting a null
hypothesis, you won't be
able to say what the expected
effect is, so you won't be
able to necessarily quantify
the impact.
PROFESSOR: No, that's
not quite right.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: So you're going
to estimate your--
you run your experiment, you're
going to get a beta,
which is your estimate,
And you're going to
get a standard error.
You reject the null, which
means you say with 95%
probability, I'm in my
confidence interval.
So you know you're somewhere
in the confidence interval.
And then beyond that, you have
an estimate of where in the
confidence interval you are.
And your best estimate for
where you are on the
confidence interval is
your point estimate.
Does that make sense?
So in terms of thinking through
the cost-benefit or
whatever, your best guess of the
effect of the program is
your point estimate,
is your beta.
If you wanted to be a little
more precise about it, you
could say--
so this is your estimate, this
is your beta hat, this is your
confidence interval, right?
Zero is over here, so you can
reject zero in this case.
But, in fact, there's a
distribution of where your
estimates are likely to be.
And when we said it was 95%
confidence interval, that's
because the probability of
being over here is 95%.
But this says you're most likely
to be right here, but
there's some probability
over here.
You're more likely to be near
beta then you are to be very--
it's not that you're equally
likely to be anywhere in your
confidence interval.
You're most likely to be right
near your point estimate.
So, in fact, if you actually
cared about the range, you
could say, well, what's the
probability I'm over here?
And calculate that.
What's the probability
I'm over here?
And you could average them to
calculate the average benefit
of your program.
Usually, though, we don't bother
to do this and usually
what we do is we say our best
estimate is that you're right
at beta hat.
That is our best estimate and
we calculate our estimate
based on that.
But in theory, you could use
the whole distribution
[INAUDIBLE].
OK.
OK, so suppose we want--
so how do we actually calculate
some of these?
So using the software helps get
a sense, intuitively, of
what these tradeoffs are
going to look like.
And I don't know that I'll have
time to go through all
this, but we'll go through
most of it, OK?
So for example, so if you run
the software and look at power
versus number of clusters--
hold on.
So how would you set this
up in the software?
So we'll talk about clustered
effects in a sec.
As we discussed, you have to
pick a significance level.
You have to pick a standardized
effect size.
That's what delta is
in the software.
So we use 0.2, OK?
In the software, it's always
a standardized effect size.
You just divide by
your standard
deviation of your outcome.
That's why you know your
actual outcome variable
because you know--
but I think the
actual effect is whatever--
people get one centimeter
longer in order to get a
standardized effect size, I
need to know the standard
deviation of my outcome
variable.
And the program is going to
give you the power as a
function of your sample
size, OK?
And one of the things that you
can see is that this is not
necessarily a linear
relationship, right?
So for example, here, we've
plotted a delta of--
effect size of 0.2 and here's
an effect size of 0.4.
So this says that with about 200
clusters, you're going to
get to a power of 0.8 with the
effect size of 0.4, but you're
still going to be at a
power of 0.2 with an
effect size of 0.2.
So the formulas are
complicated.
They're not necessarily a linear
function of your power.
When we think about power, we've
talked about a couple of
things that influence our power
in terms of the variance
of our outcome, right?
The variance of our outcome,
how big our effect size is.
And those are the basic
things that are going
to affect our power.
But there are things that we
can do in our experiment--
in the way we design our
experiment that are also going
to make our experiment more
or less powerful.
And here are some of the
things that we can do.
One thing that we can
do is we can think
about having a cluster--
so whether we whether randomize
at the individual
level or in clusters, whether we
have a baseline, whether we
use control variables or
stratification, and the type
hypothesis being tested.
All four of these are things
that we're going to do that
for a given outcome variable
and a given effect size, in
some sense, are going to
affect how powerful our
experiment is.
In some sense--
given that I may not have time
to finish everything, the one
that I want to focus on is
the clustering issue.
This is the one that is the
biggest for designing
experiments, and it often
makes a big difference.
So the intuition for clustering
is that--
so what is clustering?
Clustering is, instead of
randomizing-- suppose I want
to do an experiment on whether
the J-PAL executive ed class
improves your ability to--
whether you took this lecture
improves your understanding of
power calculation, OK?
Suppose I randomly sampled this
half of the room and gave
you my lecture and this half
was the control group.
And I flipped a coin so I split
you in halves down the
middle and I said, OK, I'm going
to flip a coin, which is
control, which is treatment.
You guys, presumably you all
sat with your friends, OK?
So people on this side of the
room are going to be more like
each other then people on that
side of the room, OK?
So I didn't get an independent
sample, right?
This group, their outcomes are
going to be correlated because
some of you are friends
and have similar
backgrounds and skills.
And this group is going
to be correlated.
On the other hand, suppose I had
gone through everyone and
randomly flipped a coin for
every person and said,
treatment or control, treatment
or control,
treatment or control?
In that case, I would've flipped
the coin 60 times and
there would be no correlation
between who is in the control
group and who is in the
treatment group because I
wouldn't have been randomizing
you into the same groups
together, OK?
By doing the cluster design,
splitting you in half and then
randomizing treatment versus
control or splitting you into
groups of 10--
you five, you 10, you 10.
You 10, you 10, you 10, and
then flipping the coin.
I have less variation, in some
sense, than if I had flipped
the coin in individual--
person by person--
because those groups are
going to be correlated.
They're going to have
similar outcomes.
So the basic point is that your
power is going to be--
the more times you flip the coin
to randomize treatment
and control, essentially, the
more power you're going to
have because the more your
different groups are going to
be independent, OK?
So to go through this again,
suppose you wanted to know--
this is, in general,
about clustering.
Suppose you wanted to know how
the outcome of the national
elections are going to be.
So you could either randomly
sample 50 people from the
entire Indian population, or
you randomly pick five
families and you ask 10
people per family what
their opinions are.
Clearly, this is going to give
you more information than this
is because those family members
are going to be
correlated, right?
I have views like my wife and
like my father, et cetera.
So we're not getting independent
views, whereas
here, you're getting, really,
50 independent data points.
And that's the same as
what we were talking
about with the class.
So this approach is going to
have more power than this
approach because of the way
you did the sample.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So is the only reason
that you would cluster,
then, just because you had to
because you had no choice--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --for political
reasons or just feasibility.
PROFESSOR: And cost.
AUDIENCE: And cost.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, and the
level of intervention.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
And we'll talk about that.
There are lots of
reasons people--
given this issue, people have
lots of good reasons for
clustering, but the point is
that there are negative
tradeoffs for sample size.
AUDIENCE: About the clusters.
If you flip the coin for all of
the class and then after,
you decide that you will select
among the people that
you have assigned, you will
select those seated--
you will select half of those
seated on the left.
Will that solve the problem--
PROFESSOR: You select half of
the ones seated on the left?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Well, it's
a different issue.
Suppose I first select the left
and now I go one by one,
flip a coin of the people
on the left.
I don't have the clustering
issue because I flipped the
coin per person.
But I have a different issue,
which is that the people I
selected are not necessarily
representative of the whole
population because I didn't pick
a representative sample.
I picked the ones who happened
to sit over here.
AUDIENCE: My question--
PROFESSOR: So there's two
different issues.
One is, essentially, how many
times you flip a coin is how
much power you have, how
independent you're thing is.
The other issue is, is this
group here representative of
the entire population?
You might think that people who
sit near the window like
to look at the river are
daydreamers and they're not as
good at math as people who don't
sit near the window.
And so I would get the effect of
my treatment on people who
like to sit near the window and
aren't as good at math.
And that might be a different
treatment effect than if I had
done it over the whole room.
So it's a different issue.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but my question
was you first draw a
random number of people that you
assign to the treatment or
to the control.
And after that, within that
people, you now say, I will
take half of those people--
I will take half that are seated
on the left and half
that are seated on the right.
PROFESSOR: I'm not sure--
let me come back to
your question.
I'm not sure I fully understand
what you're saying.
Maybe we can talk about
it afterwards.
I think what you're saying may
be about stratification.
Why don't we talk
about it later?
Because we're running a
little short on time.
In fact, can I borrow
somone's handouts?
Because I want to make sure I
cover the most important stuff
in the lecture.
Let me just see where we are.
OK.
AUDIENCE: And if you
need to, you can
take ten extra minutes.
PROFESSOR: I may do that.
I was going to ask you,
Mark, for permission.
I just wanted to see
what I had left.
OK.
So where were we?
Right.
OK.
So as I was saying, when
possible, it's better to run
clustered design.
And so a cluster randomized
trial is one in which the
units that are randomized are
clusters of units rather than
the individual units.
So I randomized a whole cluster
at a time rather than
individual person by person.
And there are lots of common
examples of this.
So the PROGRESA program, for
example, in Mexico was a
conditional cash transfer
program.
They randomized village.
Some villages were in, some
villages were out.
If a village was in,
everybody was in.
In the panchayat case
we talked about, it
was basically a village.
It was a panchayat.
So the whole panchayat
was in or the whole
panchayat was not in.
In a lot of education
experiments, we randomize at
the level of a school.
Either the whole school is in
or the whole school is out.
Sometimes you do
it as a class.
A whole class in a school is
in [UNINTELLIGIBLE] is out.
In this iron supplementation
example, it was by the family.
So there's lots of cases where
you would do this kind of
clustering.
And there are lots of good
reasons, as I've mentioned,
for doing clustering.
So one reason is you're
worried about
contamination, right?
So for example, when they're
interested in deworming, worms
are very easily--
there's a lot of
cross-contamination.
If one kid has worms, the next
kid who's also in school with
him is likely to get worms.
So if I just deworm half the
kids in the school, that's
going to have very little effect
because my control-
they're going to get
recontaminated by the kids who
weren't dewormed, right?
Or it could be the
other way around.
It could be that if I deworm
half the kids, that's enough
to knock worms out of
the population.
The control group is
also affected.
So you need to choose a level
of randomization where your
treatment is going to affect
the treatment group and not
affect the control group.
So that's a very important
reason for cluster
randomizing.
Another reason is this
feasibility consideration.
So it's often just for a
variety of reasons not
feasible to give some people the
treatment and not others.
Sometimes within a village, it's
hard to make some people
eligible for a program
and others not.
It's just sometimes hard to
treat people in the same place
differently.
And so that's often a reason
why we do cluster
randomization.
And some experiments naturally
just occur at a cluster level.
So for example, if I want to do
something that affects an
entire classroom,
like give out--
suppose I want to train
a teacher, right?
That obviously affects all the
kids in the teacher's class.
There's no way to have that only
affect half the kids in
the teacher's class.
It's just a fact of life.
So there are lots of good
reasons why we do cluster
randomized designs even though
they have negative
impacts on our power.
So as I mentioned, the reason
the cluster has a negative
impact on your power is
because the groups are
correlated.
The outcomes for the individuals
are correlated.
So, for example, if all of the
villagers are exposed to the
same weather, right?
All villagers are exposed
to the same weather.
So it could be that
the weather was
really bad in this village.
So all those people are going
to have a lower outcome, for
example, than if the
weather was good.
And so, in some sense, even if
there are 1,000 people in that
village, they all got this
common shock, which is the
negative weather, you don't
actually have 1,000
independent observations in that
village because they have
this common correlated
component, OK?
And this common correlated
component we denote by the
Greek letter rho, which is the
correlation of the units
within the same cluster.
So rho measures the correlation
between units in
the same cluster.
If rho is zero, then people in
the same cluster are just as
if they were independent.
There's no correlation.
Just as if they had been not
in the same cluster.
If rho is one, they're perfectly
correlated and it
means it they all have exactly
the same outcome, OK?
So it's somewhere between
zero and one.
And the lower the rho is, the
better you are if you're doing
a cluster randomized design.
And why is that?
It's because the problem within
a clustered randomized
design is, as I was saying, if
people were all exposed to the
same weather, it's not as if
you had 1,000 independent
people in that village.
You effectively had fewer than
1,000 because they were
correlated.
And rho captures that effect--
how much smaller, effectively,
is your sample, OK?
And the bigger rho is, the
smaller your effective sample
size is, OK?
And once again, when you do the
power calculations, you
can play with this and you'll
note that small differences in
rho make very big differences
in your power.
And I'll show you the
formula in a sec.
So often it's low, but it
can be substantial.
So in some of these test score
cases, for example, it's
between 0.2 and 0.6, which,
0.6 means that most of the
differences are coming between
groups, not within groups.
So the groups, really, are much
closer to one object.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What does
the 0.5 mean?
Are you saying that in
Madagascar, the scores on math
and language--
PROFESSOR: It's the correlation
coefficient, which is the--
technically, I believe it's the
between variation divided
by the total variation.
I think that's the formula.
Dan's shaking his head.
Good.
Excellent.
A for me.
It's what share of the variation
is coming between
groups divided by the total
share of variation.
So 0.5 means that, in some
sense, half of the variation
in your sample is coming
between groups.
AUDIENCE: Okay.
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: Isn't it within
[INAUDIBLE]?
If a rho is--
PROFESSOR: No, it's between.
Because if rho is one, then
each group is one.
Yeah, it's between.
If it was zero, then they're
independent and it's saying
that it's all coming
from within.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But here it's between
math and language
scores of one kid or between
math plus language scores of
two kids in the same group.
AUDIENCE: Or is it math and
language scores in Madagascar
are explained by--
PROFESSOR: This says
the following.
This was in Madagascar, they
sampled math and language
schools by--
they took math and language
scores for each kid by
classroom--
or by school.
I think it was by school in
this particular case.
Then they said, looking over
the whole sample that they
looked at in Madagascar, what
percentage of the variation in
test scores came
between schools
relative to within schools.
And they're saying
that half of the
variation was between schools.
OK.
So how much does this hurt
us, essentially?
So we need to adjust our
standard errors, given the
fact that these things
are correlated.
And this is the formula, which
is that for a given total
sample size, if we have clusters
of size m-- so say we
have 100 kids per school--
and intercorrelation coefficient
should be a rho,
the size of the smallest effect
we can detect increases
by this formula compared to
a non-clustered design.
So this shows you what
this looks like, OK?
So suppose you had 100
kids per school, OK?
Suppose you had 100 kids per
school and you randomized at
the school level rather
the individual level.
If your correlation coefficient
was zero, it would
be the same as if we randomized
at the individual
level because they're totally
uncorrelated.
Suppose your correlation
coefficient was 0.1--
rho was 0.1.
Then the smallest effect size
you could have would be 3.3
times larger than if you had
done an individual design.
So does that make sense
how to interpret this?
And so this illustrates that,
even with very mild
correlation coefficients-- and
we saw examples of those math
test scores that
were like 0.5.
This is only 0.1, but it already
means, in some sense,
that your experiment
can detect things--
if you had been able to
individually randomize, you
would be able to detect things
that were three times as
small, right?
Now that's a combination of
the fact that you have the
correlation coefficient
and the number
of people per cluster.
AUDIENCE: Then in the previous
slide, 0.5 does not mean half?
PROFESSOR: No, 0.5 is the
correlation-- it's rho.
AUDIENCE: No, in the
PROFESSOR: It's rho.
AUDIENCE: Then it does not mean
half of the difference--
PROFESSOR: No, it's half
of the variance.
Let me move on.
We can talk about the
formula for that.
OK.
So what this means is, if the
experimental design is
clustered, we now not only need
to consider all the other
factors we talked about before,
we also need to
consider this factor rho when
doing our power calculations.
And rho is yet another thing we
can try to estimate based
on our little survey of our
population to get a sense of
what this rho is likely to be.
And given this clustering issue,
it's very important not
just that you have a big
enough number of people
involved in your experiment, but
that you randomize across
a big enough number
of groups, right?
And the way I like to think
about is, how many times did
you flip the coin as to who
should be treatment and who
should be control?
And, in fact, it's usually the
case that the number of groups
you have is often more important
than the total
number of individuals that you
have because the individuals
are correlated within
a group, OK?
So moving on.
So I'm going to flip
through this.
This is mostly going over some
of this if you were doing the
exercise quickly.
OK.
And so this chart--
in your exercise shows you some
of the tradeoffs that you
should think about when you're
trying to decide how you
should trade off the number of
groups you have versus the
number of people within
a group, OK?
So in this particular case, a
group was a gram panchayat,
and within a group there
were villages, OK?
And there were different costs
involved in doing these
different things, right?
So going to the place involved
transportation costs to get to
the gram panchayat.
That, say, was a
couple of days.
And then it took, like, half a
day, say, for every village
you interviewed.
So that said, there's some
cost of adding a new gram
panchayat, but also some
marginal cost of adding
additional village per
gram panchayat, OK?
So you could calculate, based
on all your parameters and
power of 80% and whatever the
intercluster correlation is in
this particular case, you could
say, well, if we had
this many villages per gram
panchayat, how many gram
panchayats would we need
and how many villages
would we need, OK?
So you can do this
set of exercises
and you can say that--
and you'll note, for example,
that as we reduce the number
of gram panchayats we go to--
another way, as we add more
villages per gram panchayat, the
total number of villages
we need to survey goes up.
And in this particular case, it
doesn't go up by that much
because the intercluster
correlation is not that high.
And you could actually do this
type of calculation and you
could say, well I know
my costs are, right?
I know what my costs of
going this place are.
And I can calculate which of
these designs is the cheapest
design given what I
want to achieve.
The other thing is, in this
case, the experiment was
happening everywhere and
they were just trying
to design the survey.
But often when we're doing this,
we also need to pay for
the intervention itself.
And, at least in a lot of the
cases that I've worked with,
the cost of actually doing the
intervention is much bigger
than the cost of doing
the survey.
And so, in that case, if you
always have to treat every
village in the gram panchayat,
you can actually save a ton of
money by going down in the
number of gram panchayats and
surveying a lot more villages.
But the whole point is there
are these tradeoffs and you
need to, in deciding how you're
going to structure your
experiment and how you're
survey, you need to think
through what these tradeoffs
are, make sure you have enough
power, given your estimates of
your intercluster correlation
and sort of do the cost
minimizing thing.
OK, so in the last five minutes
or so, let me just
highlight a couple of the other
issues that come up in
thinking about power
calculations.
So as I mentioned, the cluster
design is one of the most
important ones.
And the key thing is making
sure you have enough
independent groups, where you
flip the coin to randomize
betwee treatment and control
enough times.
Some other things that matter
are baselines, control
variables, and the hypothesis
being tested.
So one minute on
each of those.
A baseline has two uses--
main uses.
One use of a baseline is that it
lets you check whether the
treatment and control
group look the
same before you started.
And if you randomized properly,
we know they should
look similar.
But you want to make sure that
your randomization was
actually carried out the way it
was supposed to be and that
it wasn't the case that people
were pulling out of the hat
until they got a treatment or
something, that they were
actually randomizing the way
they were supposed to.
And having a baseline conducted
before you start can
allow you to test that your
randomization is actually
truly random and your groups
look balanced.
The other thing is, the baseline
can actually help
reduce your survey size needed
because, but it requires you
to a survey before you start
the intervention, right?
And the reason it can reduce
your sample size is that now,
instead of just looking at, say,
test scores across kids,
I can look at the change in test
scores from before versus
after the experiment started.
And if people are really
persistent, like if the people
who did really well on the test
this year are likely to
do really well on the test
next year, that can
essentially reduce the variance
of your outcome.
It can be that the variance of
difference in test scores can
be a lot lower than the variance
in test scores.
And having a baseline can help
you for that reason.
And as this slide points out,
your evaluation costs
basically double because you
have to do two surveys, not
one survey, but the costs of
the intervention go down
because you can have a slightly
smaller sample.
So if your intervention is
really expensive relative to
your survey, this can
make a lot of sense.
If your survey is really
expensive relative to your
intervention, you might
not want to do this.
And to figure out how this is
going to affect your power,
you need to know yet another
fact, which is how correlated
are people's outcomes
over time, right?
What's the correlation between
how well I do on a test today
and how well I do on
a test tomorrow?
And some things are really
correlated and some things are
not that correlated.
And a baseline really helps you
on things that are really
correlated.
Another thing that can help
you is stratification.
So what stratification can do
is, stratification says,
suppose I--
in some ways, it's conceptually
a little bit like
a baseline, which is, suppose I
know that all of the people
who live in this village tend
to have similar outcomes and
all of the people who live in
this village tend to have
similar outcomes.
And all of the people who live
in this village tend to have
similar outcomes.
If I can then randomize by
village, I can compare the
people in each village
to each other, OK?
So if I'm looking within
village, if people in villages
tend to be similar and I can
randomize within village, if I
look within villages, the
difference between the
treatment and the
control group is
going to be less noisy.
So stratifying is basically a
way of saying I'm going to
make sure my sample is balanced
across the treatment
and control groups within
certain subgroups of the
population.
And then I'm going to compare
within those subgroups of the
population when I
do my analysis.
And once again, we can
think this as a
way of reducing noise.
That if people in similar
villages tend to be similar,
if I only compare treatmet and
control within the same
village, the noise there
is going to be smaller.
So in some sense,
it's similar.
So some things we tend to
stratify by, if we know the
baseline value of the outcome,
we can sometimes stratify by
that because we know that the
effects are going to be
similar for people who have very
similar baseline values.
Or often, I think,
geographically we often tend
to do that.
So basically, we think that
people in certain areas tend
to be similar so we're going
to make sure our treatments
and controls are balanced in
those areas as a way of
reducing noise.
And the final thing we want to
mention is the hypothesis
being tested, which is, the more
things you want to test,
the bigger your sample is
going to need to be.
So for example, are we
interested in the difference
between two treatments
as well as the
treatment versus control?
If so, we need a much bigger
sample because we not only
need to be able to tell the
treatment versus the control
but we also need to be able to
tell the two treatments from
each other, right?
So suppose you have two
different treatments.
Are you interested in just the
overall effect of each of the
two treatments?
Or are you interested in
whether the treatments
interact produces a different
effect if they happen
together, right?
The more things you're
interested in, the bigger your
sample needs to be because you
need to design your sample to
be big enough to answer each of
these different questions.
Another thing, for example, you
were interested in testing
whether the effect is different
in different
subpopulations.
Do you just want to know the
average effect of your program
or do you want to know if it was
different in rural areas
versus urban areas?
If you want to know if it's
different in rural versus
urban areas, you're going to
need a big enough sample in
rural areas and a big enough
sample in urban areas that you
can compare the difference
between them.
So the more different things
that you want to test,
obviously, the bigger
your experiment's
going to need to be.
And a lot of times, in actually
designing the
experiment, this is something
that comes up all the time,
that you will very quickly
figure out that the number of
questions you would like to
answer is far bigger than the
sample size you can afford.
And one of the really important
conversations you
need to have as you're
starting to design an
experiment are, which are the
really critical questions that
I really need to know
the answer to?
So for example, in a project
I was recently doing in
Indonesia, it turned out that
the government really wanted
to know whether this program
would work differently in
urban versus rural areas because
they had a view that
urban areas are really
different.
And they were willing to do
different programs in urban
versus rural areas.
So we designed our whole sample
to make sure we had
enough sampled in urban areas
and in rural areas that we
could test those two
things apart.
That almost doubled the size
of the experiment, but the
government thought that was
important enough that they
really wanted to do that.
The point here is that--
that was the one they
wanted to focus on.
There was a million
other things we
could have done instead.
And so it's really important
to think about, before you
design the experiment, what the
few key things you want to
test are because, as I said, net
you're never going to have
enough money to test all
things you want.
That's sort of a universal
truth.
So just to conclude, we've talk
about in this lecture--
going back to the basic
statistics of how you're going
to analyze the experiment,
thinking about how noisy your
outcome is going to be and how
you're going to compute your
confidence intervals,
how big your effect
size is going to be.
That's all what goes into doing
a power calculation.
You also need to do some
guess work, right?
The power calculation is going
to require you to estimate how
big your sample is
going to be--
sorry, how much variance there's
going to be, what your
effect size is going to be.
You have to make some
assumptions.
And a little bit of pilot
testing before the experiment
begins can be really useful,
I think, mostly
for thinking about--
just collecting some data
can be useful to
estimate these variances.
The power calculations can
help you think about this
question of how many treatments
you can afford to
have, and can I afford to do
three different versions of
the program or do I really need
to just pick one or two?
How do I make this tradeoff of
more clusters versus more
observations per cluster?
The power calculation can
be very helpful here.
And the other thing, and in some
sense, the place I find
power calculations the most
useful, especially because
there is a bit of guesswork in
power calculations and you get
rough rules of thumb.
You don't get precise answers
because it depends on the
assumptions.
But what I find this is really
useful for is whether this is
feasible or not, right?
Is this something where I'm
kind of in the right range
where I think I can get
estimates, or where there's no
chance, no matter how successful
this program is,
that I'm going to be able to
pick it up in my data because
the variable is just
way too noisy.
And it's really important that
you do the power calculation,
particularly--
both for structuring how to
design the experiment, but
particularly to make sure you're
not going to waste a
lot of time and money doing
something where you're going
to have no hope of
picking it up.
Because a study which is
underpowered is going to waste
a lot of everyone's time and
you're very frustrated.
Very frustrating for
everyone involved.
So you want to make sure you do
this right before you start
because otherwise, you're going
to end up spending a lot
of time, money, and effort on
an experiment and ending up
not being able to conclude
much of anything.
OK.
Thanks very much.